[Musik]
mein name ist kambodscha ich bin
schwanger und im pilot in der
kreisstaffel ich mein gerät darüber 58
in dem fall bewaffnet mit einer 62
millimeter mini kam von der firma dylan
kadenz 1000 schuss pro minute und
ungefähr 1000 meter
[Musik]
weiter immer der flughäfen in dem fall
passiert das auf einen schlafsack der
aber an 150 meter langen seil bis zu
sechs pilatus kurz danach gezogen wird
bevor wir diesen markt finden können
haben ist mir die leute werden von
unseren rat als offizier der das ziel
haben radler erkennt genau wie bei jeder
anderen anfangs fahrzeuge zum beispiel
im auge seite werden wir dann
hingeleitet ob dieses sehen müssen wo
sie die tiere mit unseren augen und
danach bekommen wir die steuerfrage
haben wir das frei abfließen des
schlafsacks befindet erklärt in die
karte traf der abend bereits reagiert
und je nachdem kann man eben sagen wir
mal hat er viel getroffen aber nicht
dann haben wir möglicherweise - nizza
anflug von dem fluss christa
durchschnittlich einsatz 30 bis 50
prozent bei 7 150 kennt sich vorstellen
wie möglich ein potenzielles ziel
treffen und den entsprechenden schritten
[Musik]